[Music]
this morning on a special edition of the
dish we introduced you to Jorge Vallejo
he is the chef and owner of Quinto Neel
a Mexico City dining destination that
has been named one of the world's 50
best restaurants for his new venture
he's gone off the beaten path to create
a venue honoring Mayan culture an
elegant combination of things modern and
ancient as we saw on a visit with the
chef on the Yucatan Peninsula in the
heart of Mexico on this lush plantation
here's where picking some beautiful
flowers
chef Jorge Vallejo tends to his garden
flower and his harvest weather grown in
the earth or in these ancient planters
it all supplies the bounty of his new
restaurant it she which means corn in
Mayan it's the story we want to tell to
the people one of the spinal cords of
the Mexican gastronomy or the Mexican
culture it's about corn so for me is a
very I would say democratic ingredient
because it's not about the monetary
value it's all about the flavor the the
pureness of the ingredient and that's
why we want us to say we are currently
his mission to distinguish a Mayan
eating experience by preparing humble
ingredients with modern Flair and cook
it from you know only from one side like
escolar a buttery fish from the Gulf of
Mexico when I gave it it takes these
flavors what are the main main life I
look at you just digging it up look at
you feel there's no penis of the of the
fish this is really good for hey it's
delicious
I hope you enjoyed equally as delicious
the beauty of this setting it seemed
anchors chablis a luxury resort built in
the grounds of an old Hacienda his
restaurants have become a retreat for
global visitors and Vallejo says
recently have been a bridge to Mexico's
northern neighbor the US I will say
ninety percent of the people that comes
into the restaurant are not Mexicans
actually we had to give English lessons
to our waiters because probably out of
that 90 percent sixty percent of the
people are Americans extreme is 45
minutes from Merida the Yucatan capital
but it feels like a place from another
time so this was actually the factory
where they made but a 19th century
plantation that once produced rope now
provides relaxation for its customers
and employment for the local community
so much of this area is influenced by
Mayan culture it is it's all about Mayan
culture the people still know these days
they are very proud about their culture
they're very proud about being Mayans
they are actually the ones that keep the
tradition they're the ones that keep the
flavors they're the ones that keep the
keep the environment Mexico is not one
thing if you go to Oaxaca they have
their own traditions they their own
flavors even their own past influence
yeah his own food story started early
when you were a kid instead of toys for
Christmas you would ask for a roast
chicken
I can eat chicken and rice every day I
have a three-year-old daughter probably
the kids are the most wise people in the
world because they live now the present
for me being a cook or serving people
it's about that that kitchen obsessed
kid who had trouble concentrating in
school decided to give cooking a try I
was just in my own world I was lucky
enough to find something that I can lose
myself which is cooking but
she also quenches the thirst for another
ancient tradition tequila was born in
Mexico in Jalisco
Louis Ronson and luis alberto flores
moon yo are experts in tequila you don't
need to pour that much
[Music]
Hakeem has the largest tequila
collection in the world
3800 bottle strong its oldest the Jose
Cuervo which has been around for 240
years if you want to try our Mexican
dish would not be complete fire fire
without a lesson in the proper etiquette
of tequila sipping because tequila like
the cuisine here in this pocket of
paradise is to be savored oh wow that's
very smooth Tina may be really high
quality spirit that you can enjoy just a
jus enjoy cognac for chef Alejo the way
to honor his Mexican heritage is to
bring that Mayan cuisine to the world
stage and that's what we want to
showcase here in the in the restaurant
the pureness of the ingredients but how
can really works in a luxury audience
mission accomplished because quintanilla
has been rated one of the top
restaurants in the world yes
no I'm filled you know very proud about
what we achieved already and just as I
told you I'm still learning I'm still
like wanted to to do more so for me of
course is Sam as you're saying mission
accomplished but still not finished he's
a very humble guy created so much